steve jobs
there's uh two things i want to mention
there
one once again the harshness but a very
different kind
and the second is team building so on
the harshness
he is much harsher than elon
in a way in the following way i'm
having a sense that you will not like
this but i'd like to defend it
is he loses his quite a bit
he was famously at least especially
early on being very emotional
his letting passion dominate the
discussion there'd be a lot of firings
there will be a lot of mean
things said to people
i don't know what you make of that how
much is a leader are you allowed to just
lose your
in your love for the thing you're doing
and how effective is that as a leader
you shouldn't be doing that very often
so you can look back at me and say well
jocko here's the most profitable company
that's ever existed
and so you're wrong well
going back to that multitude of
characteristics that human beings can
have
well it's the same thing with businesses
it's the same thing with companies
steve jobs was off the charts in some of
his traits
his ability to understand design
yeah his ability to understand human
interface
with computer systems so so far off the
charts
that despite his bad temper
emotional behavior
the company still thrived that's
that can happen you can have people that
you there's you can have people that are
horrible leaders
that develop something that's so
universally outstanding that you end up
with a
a company that's successful i the reason
i mean i get asked that
a bunch you know people always ask me
because i say look you shouldn't be
you shouldn't be losing your temple as
temper as a leader
well what about steve jobs he used to
yell and scream all the time great
i might when people say that to me i say
oh okay are you as good as
at design as steve jobs was were you as
good
are you as good at marketing yeah as
steve jobs was
there's he had a certain amount of
skills that were
off the charts and so he was able to be
successful
despite the fact that he would lose his
temper treat people horribly that's not
that's not good
it's not good and it would have been
even more successful
if you if you wouldn't had those
characteristics now you might say well
he his anger is what pushed things
well let me ask you this
what leader wins the leader
whose team is afraid who the
the team who execute executes the
mission because they're afraid of their
leader
or executes the task because they're
afraid of their leader or the team
that loves their leader so much that
they don't want to let them down
which team wins you're implying a
confidence
that love is more powerful than fear but
i'm not so sure
this is the machiavelli question you're
saying ultimately it's always better to
lead
by inspiration and love than by
by putting the fear
into the team what i'm what i'm saying
is that i've seen
countless times is me leading through my
authority
leading through my rank leading through
punitive measures is infinitely worse
than me and you working together as a
team to win
on the second point of steve jobs is uh
he
has this idea a philosophy of a players
where you have a group
like the power and the productivity
of a group of what he called a players
is invaluable so you want to get a team
of
people who are the best at what they do
but the most important aspect to him
was that a single quote-unquote b player
on the team destroys the entire
productivity of the team
is there something that brings true to
that so he was
this could be a temper thing but vicious
about
firing and removing the uh what he's
felt was a toxic b player in a team
so a players feed off of each other
unless there's one b
player present depends on the nature of
the b player
is the player is the player a b player
because he's a little bit lazy is he a b
player
because he doesn't have good vision
is he a b player because he's got a big
ego
and always thinks he's right and now
creates conflict in the team so there's
a bunch of different b
players look if you're working for me
and you're kind of a b player but guess
what you're a grinder and you get stuff
done
i want you on the team you might not be
the smartest person i have
but i know that you're committed to the
team
yeah and i want you on the team so
you're a b player
but that's okay now if if you're
lex with a giant ego i'd rather have
i'd rather have lex that's not quite as
smart because i got other people that
are smart
i got other people that are smart on the
team look you're going to need some
smart people on the team
but a team is made up it's a team
and so you take these different
components of a team and if you have
complementary components you'll end up
with a superior team
than just basing it on the level of and
what's an a player
sometimes in the seal teams they would
get something called the
stacked platoon and what that would be
is
someone you know some senior person in
that platoon
would manipulate and and and maneuver
to get the quote best guys that he could
in that platoon so you know the most
experienced guys
the person that had great great
reputations and sometimes those platoons
would be great
sometimes they would implode because
what you end up with is a bunch of
a players and now no one wants to
follow anyone else no one wants to agree
with anyone else everyone wants to do it
my way not it's my way not lex's way lex
is stupid no you're stupid
we end up with problems so can
one person derail a team absolutely
under good leadership one person should
not derail a team
this could be a tech thing too there's
some
multiplying effect of just pure
excellence no matter the personalities
i think for steve jobs he doesn't
the ego doesn't matter none of that
matters what matters is the quality of
the output
the the genius of the result and that
somehow multiplies itself
and the eagles actually like one of the
problems with egos
is uh like what does ego usually say it
says i'm much better than you
when you have people that are really
good together it's very hard for the ego
to flourish because you're like
constantly being shown that you're not
as good
and there's a competition so like i
think to his
his idea was that like if you get people
that are really good at what they do
it turns as opposed to you being
complacent and not doing much
and thinking you're better than everyone
else and your opinion is better is you
almost getting in that competitive race
you know that magic that happens when
you're
at the end of a marathon and you're just
like head to head like
you're just going full steam with a
person that is as good as you there's no
place for ego there
which is great which is great let's use
that example
you and i are racing we're at the end of
the marathon we're both
highly competitive highly competitive we
have massive egos and we both want to
win
we both want to win so bad
that we we give everything we've got
that's totally positive right yeah isn't
that totally positive
now imagine this same thing
we're in a race we're in a marathon
we're in the last hundred meters
it's you against me and and our egos are
huge and we're pushing to win
and you start to pull ahead of me and my
ego is so big
and i hate losing so much
that i somehow accidentally push my knee
up against your foot on a backstride and
throw you onto your face
yeah so that's what ego is an
awesome driver unless you let your ego
control you
yeah and you let ego drive your
decision-making process in which case it
turns into
an incredible problem so you might have
someone that is
excellent you might have someone that's
outstanding
you might have some someone that's tens
across the board
but their ego is so big that big that
they can't work with other people
they can't accept anyone else's ideas
they can't compromise on something
because they think their idea is better
all the time
and that is going to be problematic
and i don't want them on the team now as
a good leader guess what i'll do
i'll put them into a situation where i
can utilize their best aspects
but not have their ego destroy the team
so i might say hey lex you know what i
actually want you to take lead on this
part of the project over here and since
you're so
smart and you you work so hard i know
you're going to pull ahead of everyone
else so
you grind on that once you get that
result
give it to me and i'm going to
disseminate it to the team basically so
i i
isolate you from wrecking yourself and
the rest of the team
with your giant ego
you